a mix-up but federal prosecutors suggest
criminal charges may have been filed
against WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange
an unsealed court document with the
Santa's name raises new questions about
the investigation of WikiLeaks his role
in exposing thousands of emails from
Democrats before the 2016 election
Jonathan Vigliotti is outside Ecuador's
Embassy in London Assange is home for
the last six years Jonathan good morning
good morning John and Assange has
remained inside this embassy in large
part out of fear that if he were to
leave he be extradited to the US those
fears perhaps confirm this morning after
what appears to be a simple mix-up of
paperwork this apparent indictment came
to light late last night through a court
filing in an unrelated sex crimes case
it appears US federal prosecutors
accidentally conflated two cases because
they're filing abruptly changes course
on the second page referring to the
publicity surrounding the case and
revealing the fact that Assange had been
charged the US Attorney's Office
confirmed to us the court filing was
quote made in error the disclosure comes
as the Special Counsel Robert Mueller is
investigating whether President Trump or
his associates colluded with Russia
during the 2016 election Assange as
WikiLeaks published thousands of emails
that year that Russian hackers stole
from the Democratic Party Assange has
been holed up in the Ecuadorian Embassy
since 2012 in a desperate attempt to
initially avoid extradition to Sweden on
rape charges which have now been dropped
his lawyer says the government bringing
criminal charges against his client for
publishing truthful information is quote
a dangerous path for a democracy to take
now we have reached out to the
Department of Justice to get some
clarification on these charges if they
exist in Gale at this point they have
not reached back out to us all right
Jonathan Vigliotti on the case in London
thank you